hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and the final new
admiral ryogyukyu or greenbull has
finally been revealed we all knew that
this guy would be powerful and there
were many theories out there about his
devil fruit and other abilities but i
don't think that all of us realized just
how dangerous this man would be his
plant-based devil fruit was able to
instantly incapacitate dozens of kaido
subordinates including the likes of king
and queen which is absolutely insane and
his devil fruit is actually far more
dangerous than you even realize so let
me explain you guys know how this works
if you enjoy our one piece videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps with that youtube
algorithm oh and subscribing to the
channel and hitting that notification
bell is a completely free way of
directly supporting the channel finally
this video will of course contain one
piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned
green bull aka ryogyukyu aka aramaki
attained the rank of admiral during the
two-year time skip along with admiral
fujitora the two of them replaced aokiji
and akainu after aokiji resigned from
the marines and akainu was promoted to
fleet admiral according to doflamingo
both green bowl and fujitora are
overpowered monsters and this was
certainly proven to be true once we
finally saw green bull in action against
the beast pirates what's more we know
that green bull and fujitora fought sabo
and several other revolutionary
commanders during the reverie and
greenville seems to have emerged from
that battle unscathed which is in itself
a testament to his incredible power we
know that green bull has apparently been
fasting for over three years which
implies that he is able to survive
without food this was a huge mystery in
the one piece community until very
recently when the true nature of his
devil fruit was finally revealed now
that we know his true power we can
assume that he doesn't need to eat
because he can absorb nutrients from
other people by literally draining them
that is exactly what he did to dozens of
beast pirates including king and queen
green bull can also create different
types of plants from his body and he can
then control and manipulate those plants
for instance he can grow a huge flower
from his back and make that flower
rotate like a helicopter which allows
him to fly he can also transform his
fingers into tree branches that extend
far from his body and he can then use
those branches to impale multiple
enemies and drain their nutrients
leaving the enemies shriveled and
incapacitated on the surface green bull
appears to admire akainu aka fleet
admiral sakazuki and he even vows to
kill luffy in order to impress the fleet
admiral but green bull also seems to
regularly defy sakazuki's orders he
refused the order to kick fujitora out
of marijua during the reverie and he
then decided to go into wano on his own
initiative despite being told not to by
the fleet admiral he even actively tried
to conceal his location and actions from
sakazuki this tells me that there may be
more to green bull than meets the eye
and that goes for both his personality
and his devil fruit at first glance
green bull's devil fruit seems to be
extremely powerful and versatile and it
appears to have the properties of a
paramecia on top of that this devil
fruit is somewhat similar to the mossa
mosanomi a plant-based devil fruit from
film z even though appearing in the
movie means that it is a non-canonical
devil fruit the fact that it is similar
to green bull's fruit and that it was
also classified as a paramecia suggests
that green bull's devil fruit is a
paramecia as well but
not so fast wano has placed a huge
emphasis on mythical zone type devil
fruits with kaido orochi yamato and
onimaru all having mythical zones and
with the wano arc also revealing that
luffy's devil fruit is actually a
mythical zone i know that some people
are kind of getting tired of all these
mythical zone reveals in mono but we
still have to consider the possibility
that green bull has a mythical zone
after all no real plant can just impale
entire human beings and drain them of
their nutrients and fluids in seconds
but certain mythical plants such as the
tree youkai named jubako do have such
abilities in japanese mythology
juboko is a supernatural tree that
attacks humans by changing its branches
into sharp tubes driving those tubes
into its victims and then draining the
humans of their blood you have to admit
that this sounds a lot like green bull's
power and if it is true that he actually
has a mythical yokai zone this would
mean that all three current admirals
have a different type of devil fruit
with kizaru having a logia fujitora
having a paramecia and green bull having
a mythical zone honestly even if you are
a bit burned out on mythical zones you
have to admit that this would be pretty
cool for more on the juboko and other
youkai that greenbull's devil fruit may
be based on i'm bringing in another
member of our anime opera team axel
beats hey everyone you've probably seen
a few of my videos here on anime uproar
but animak specifically wanted me to
jump in on this one because i got a
degree in history from university i
lived in japan for a while and just
generally love learning about japanese
history mythology and folktales oda has
continuously brought in this idea of
world myths throughout the series for
example marco's phoenix fruit magellan
creating poisonous hydras the boa
sisters mirroring the gorgons chaka and
pel being based on egyptian deities and
so on and so on but especially recently
with this huge emphasis on zone fruit
since we started wano we have seen a
huge influx of mythological inspiration
in the past few years alone we've seen
the syriu kitsune yamato no rochi onudo
and the okuchino magami which is
probably why despite having two vacant
admiral seats post time skip which
needed to be filled we didn't get
introduced to green bull really until
just now if we look at the other new
admiral fujitora his role is supposed to
be one which mirrors smoker and as such
he was introduced to us in dressrosa
where his role juxtaposes smoker's role
in alabasta in the same way i'm sure as
we learn more about green bull we will
see more direct parallels between him
and juano's themes however almost
immediately we're seeing his abilities
be in line with japanese mythology which
is pretty cool because typically they
show that kind of thing through zone
devil fruits but like magellan it seems
like green bull has a paramecia although
like animak mentioned earlier how cool
would it be to have a mythical zone
plant-based devil fruit all we actually
know about the specifics of green bull's
fruit so far though is that it seems to
be able to produce manipulate and
control flowers and plants we don't know
the extent of these powers yet but if we
look to the other admirals it's likely
pretty insane i think the best place to
begin looking at possible abilities for
green bowl though is likely looking at
plant-based yokai and myths which might
be incorporated originally i was a bit
hesitant but after seeing chapter 1050
i'm more than certain this will be
worked into his fruit in some way or
another towards the end of chapter 1050
we see him piercing through some of
kaido's crew including king and queen
and seemingly sucking the life out of
them even queen just seems to be skin
and bones and that's a pretty big change
for them which leads us to the first and
most direct yokai inspiration as animak
mentioned the juboko this is more or
less a vampire tree it's a yokai that
appears on places that used to be
battlefields the plant grows soaked in
the blood from the battle and all the
dead people who were laid to rest around
them once the jubico grows it begins
targeting humans that pass by it turning
its branches into piercing straws and
using them to suck the blood out of its
victims something which has the added
benefit of keeping the djiboco looking
pristine and when you look at what he's
doing in 1053 it looks exactly like he's
draining king and queen in the same way
and god does this man look pristine the
jubico also offers defensive options
though the okay can actually heal itself
so while he might not have a logia he
might at least be able to regenerate
like one similar to how marco does this
siphoning ability might also be related
to the modendake a bamboo yokai that
feeds on souls but there doesn't seem to
be any mention of souls here so i doubt
he's actually referring to that but it's
still worth mentioning just based on the
siphoning action we might also be able
to look at the nin menju another famous
japanese tree folk legend and this one
being a much more simple thing the nin
menju is just a tree which blooms
flowers that look like human heads and
in some of the more scary variants of
the stories these heads are able to
laugh or they would even become real
heads
something which might be a cool mix of
these myths would be if greenball was
able to absorb enough energy from other
people and rather than just sprouting
heads he could sprout entire bodies
making him a literal one-man army once
he has time to set up in terms of more
modern stories like anime manga comics
or cartoons these are filled with
characters like green bull who use
plants as the core of their abilities so
looking at those might also give us some
ideas of what he might be able to do
from the west we have characters like
groot swamp thing and poison ivy while
anime and manga offer characters like
mimosa or charlotte from black clover
kurama from yuyu haksho or kamui woods
and ibarra from my hero academia there
are definitely a ton of characters who
have similar power basis but between
them it's pretty common to control vines
use pheromones or aroma to manipulate
people heal themselves or others have
some select poison abilities be pretty
great for capturing or holding people
prisoner having thorn-based attacks or
growing specific plants and while many
of the earlier abilities are pretty
straightforward the idea of growing
plants is the one that is least often
explored but the most deadly we could
almost look at this as a very upgraded
version of usop's pop greens like usopp
usually in these stories we see things
like venus fly traps cacti mushrooms and
pitcher plants being created but there's
a few very deadly plants which could be
used in interesting ways and never get
mentioned for example the angel trumpet
plant if consumed can cause
hallucinations so intense that people
have been recorded cutting off their own
tongue and downstairs bits because they
lost their grounding in reality and
there are plenty of psychoactive plants
like this which could fall into this
category as well but scarier than the
plants that you would consume are those
you can't even touch
giant hogweed sap makes you allergic to
the sun for days at a time bloodroot sap
can necrotize skin tissue the manchenil
tree is so toxic that just touching it
can make your skin blister small amounts
of it can poison entire water supplies
and it was even used as a torture device
simply by tying people to it and even
smoke created from burning this plant
would immediately blind you and finally
the deadliest of all and the most
fitting for a one piece name the gimpy
gimbi bush it's covered in poison
needle-like hairs that just on contact
has been quoted feeling like hot acid
and electricity being put on you at the
same time but the worst part of this
plant though is how long the effects
last it can go from days
to weeks to months or even years of
consistent pain all that to say oda
seems to definitely be taking an
interest in mythology when it comes to
green bull's powers but if he fully dove
into what real world nature has to offer
green bull could be one of the most
terrifying characters in all of one
piece and while you might be saying that
there's no way oda would use any of
these terribly toxic plants in the
series can i please redirect your
attention to don krieg's poison gas the
amyudace mushroom crocodile's hook
magellan's toxins marigolds poisons
caesar clowns fumes smiley the armored
stone fishes skin the series is full of
increasingly deadly poisons and toxins
and this would likely be no different
thank you so much axel for that
excellent rundown of the possible
mythical inspirations for green bulls
devil fruit and also thank you for going
full botanist on us in order to give us
an idea of what other crazy powers green
bull might possess i think that oda has
kept green bull on the sidelines until
now for a good reason and i believe that
he will turn out to be an extremely
important and insanely dangerous
character especially since his current
mission appears to be killing luffy and
taking his head to a kainu no wonder
that so many people are afraid of this
guy to the point that the fleet admiral
didn't even want him on wano because of
all the potential carnage that green
bull might unleash on that country so
what do you guys think does green bull
have a standard paramecia devil fruit or
does he have a mythical zone model
jubico or something along those lines
also what is green bull really planning
is he loyal to fleet admiral sakazuki or
does he have an agenda of his own
finally do you think that green bull or
ryokyugyu aka aramaki might actually be
from wano do you buy the theory that he
may be a blood relative of zoro
definitely leave your thoughts down in
the comments below i always love hearing
from you if you're looking for a video
to watch next check out my recent video
on rox d zebic and the theory that he
could be luffy's other grandpa link in
the description if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more one piece
content in the future leave a quick like
it helps me out a lot and of course if
you're new here or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet remember that
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
completely free way of directly
supporting the channel and it means a
lot you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys